>>> THIS MORNING WE HAVE
EXCLUSIVE NEW CNN REPORTING,
DONALD TRUMP'S LAWYERS ARE NOW
IN DIRECT TALKS WITH THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT ABOUT THEIR CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION OF JANUARY 6.
THE TALKS ARE SAID TO THE
FOCUSED ON WHETHER CONVERSATIONS
THE FORMER PRESIDENT HAD CAN BE
KEPT FROM INVESTIGATORS UNDER
EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE.
KATELYN POLANTZ IS LIVE FOR US
IN WASHINGTON WITH THIS VERY
LATEST.
WHAT CAN YOU TELL US?
>> BRIANNA, THEY'RE TALKING,
THAT'S CRIMINAL INVESTIGATORS
LOOKING INTO JANUARY 6th AND
DONALD TRUMP'S DEFENSE LAWYERS,
AND WHAT THEY ARE TALKING ABOUT
RIGHT NOW ARE THESE
CONVERSATIONS THAT TRUMP WAS
HAVING IN THE WHITE HOUSE AND
HIS INTEREST IN KEEPING THOSE
CONVERSATIONS ESSENTIALLY FROM
THE FEDERAL GRAND JURY PROBE.
THIS DEVELOPMENT AND IT'S A
NOTABLE ONE AS WE TRY TO
UNDERSTAND HOW MUCH THIS
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION IS ABOUT
TRUMP, IT COMES AS PART OF THE
STORY OF GRAND JURY ACTIVITY
WE'VE SEEN IN RECENT WEEKS,
SPECIFICALLY WE KNOW OF THOSE
TWO TOP OFFICIALS WHO WORKED FOR
MIKE PENCE AND THEN THE TWO
PATS, CIPOLLONE, PHILBIN, FROM
THE WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL'S OFFICE
ALL SUBPOENAED TO BE TESTIFIED
TO THE GRAND JURY IN D.C., BUT
WHAT WE KNOW OF THEIR TESTIMONY
SO FAR FROM THE SEPARATE HOUSE
INVESTIGATION IS THOSE FOUR HAVE
NOT BEEN WILLING AT THIS TIME TO
TALK ABOUT DIRECT CONVERSATIONS
THEY HAD OR WITNESSED WITH
TRUMP.
SO OVER THE LAST WEEK A COURT
FIGHT BETWEEN THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT AND TRUMP OVER
EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE HAS BEEN
BREWING, WE'RE EXPECTING THAT
THAT COULD TAKE PLACE UNDER
SEAL, AND THAT'S WHERE THESE
DIRECT TALKS COME IN.
THEY ARE ABOUT TRUMP TRYING TO
PREVENT MORE DISCLOSURES TO THE
GRAND JURY ABOUT HIMSELF BEFORE
AND HON JANUARY 6.
SO HISTORY SUGGESTS HE MAY NOT
BE SUCCESSFUL IN THAT BECAUSE
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT MAY BE
ABLE TO GET ACCESS, BUT I ALSO
WANT TO TAKE A STEP BACK FOR A
SECOND.
THIS FIRST INDICATION OF DIRECT
TALKS IS PRETTY TELLING ABOUT
WHAT THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT IS
LOOKING TO LEARN.
WHAT'S ALSO PRETTY TELLING IS
WHAT WE ARE LEARNING IS
HAPPENING BEHIND THE SCENES WITH
TRUMP AND HIS LAWYERS.
OUR REPORTING TEAM ON THIS WE
HAVE HEARD FROM MULTIPLE SOURCES
THAT THERE IS CONCERN AMONG
TRUMP'S LAWYERS THAT HE COULD BE
INDICTED.
THEY ARE WORKING ON DEFENSE
STRATEGIES RIGHT NOW.
BUT TRUMP BEING TRUMP, HE'S
SKEPTICAL.
BRIANNA, WE HAVE HEARD HE'S
STILL KEEPING TIES WITH PEOPLE
WHO MAY BECOME CENTRAL IN THIS
PROBE, EVEN THOUGH HIS ADVISERS
TELL HIM THAT MAY NOT BE THE
BEST IDEA.
BACK TO YOU.
>> YEAH, INDEED.
KATELYN POLANTZ, THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
>>> JOINING US NOW DANYA PERRY
AND ELLIE HONING, CNN'S SEEN
LEGAL ANALYST.
ELLIE, WHAT DOES IT TELL US THAT
HIS LAWYERS ARE IN DIRECT
CONTACT WITH THE DOJ AND WHAT
DOESN'T IT TELL US?
>> IT TELLS US THAT DONALD TRUMP
IS TAKING THIS SERIOUSLY OR AT
LEAST HIS LAWYERS ARE TAKING
THIS SERIOUSLY.
IT IS NOT UNUSUAL, I SHOULD SAY,
FOR LAWYERS TORE SOMEBODY WHO
HAS NOT YET BEEN INDICTED TO BE
IN CONTACT WITH PROSECUTORS.
IT MAY FOUND LIKE THAT'S
SHOCKING BUT IT IS QUITE COMMON
BECAUSE AS A DEFENSE LAWYER IF
YOU CAN ESTABLISH CONTACT WITH
PROSECUTORS YOU CAN GET PERHAPS
INFORMATION OUT OF THEM.
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO TELL YOU
ANYTHING THEY SHOULDN'T TELL YOU
BUT YOU MAY GET A SENSE OF
TIMELINE, OF WHAT THEY'RE
INTERESTED IN.
THAT IS VERY MUCH IN YOUR
CLIENT'S INTEREST.
IT DOES NOT TELL US THAT DONALD
TRUMP IS CERTAIN TO GET
INDICTED.
IT TELLS US THAT IT'S IN PLAY
AND BOTH SIDES ARE AWARE OF THE
POSSIBILITY.
>> DANYA, LOOK, I MEAN, THIS IS
AN UNPRECEDENTED SITUATION,
THERE'S NOTHING REMOTE LIE LIKE
IT IN AMERICAN HISTORY BUT THE
CLOSEST IS THE NIXON PRESIDENCY
AND THIS DEBATE AROUND
EXECUTIVE.
WEREN'T A LOT OF THE FAULT LINES
MADE CLEARER BY NIXON V. UNITED
STATES THAT EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE
HOLDS BUT NOT IN THE CASE OF
POTENTIAL CRIMINAL CONDUCT OR
ORDERS.
>> I THINK THIS IS A RELATIVELY
EASY ONE AND IT SOUNDS LIKE DOJ
IS GETTING OUT IN FRONT OF IT,
THEY'RE PREEMPTIVELY TRYING TO
LITIGATE THIS ISSUE TO GET AN
ANSWER AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE.
WE HAVE THE NIXON PRECEDENT THAT
IS RIGHT ON POINT AND THAT IS
NOT GOING TO BE IN PRESIDENT
TRUMP'S FAVOR, AND THEN WE'VE
GOT MORE RECENTLY TRUMP HAD
BROUGHT AN ACTION WHEN THE
NATIONAL ARCHIVES WAS TRYING TO
PRODUCE DOCUMENTS TO THE SELECT
COMMITTEE, AND THAT WAS DECIDED
BY THE DISTRICT COURT, THE
APPELLATE COURT AND THE SUPREME
COURT IN A MATTER OF JUST THREE
MONTHS, WHERE THEY HANDILY SAID,
NO, THIS PRIVILEGE IS NOT YOURS,
FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP T BELONGS
TO THE NOW CURRENT PRESIDENT.
SO I THINK FOR THAT REASON AND
ALSO BECAUSE A LOT OF THE
CONVERSATIONS HE HAD WERE
PRECISELY NOT IN HIS CAPACITY AS
PRESIDENT.
IT WAS NOT -- I MEAN, IT IS NOT
THE FUNCTION OF A PRESIDENT TO
SIT THERE IN PLACE FOR 187
MINUTES AND DO NOTHING.
SO HE WAS ACTING AS A CANDIDATE
AND NOT AN EXECUTIVE AND I THINK
THAT THIS WOULD BE A QUICK TRIP
TO THE SUPREME COURT TO GET A
RULING THAT THE EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE DOES NOT APPLY HERE.
>> I AGREE THAT DONALD TRUMP IS
UNLIKELY TO WIN IN THE COURTS ON
EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE, BUT THE
STRATEGIC UPSIDE THERE IS DELAY.
I MEAN, WE KNOW DONALD TRUMP IS
THE MASTER OF THE ART OF DELAY
AND IF HE DOES ASSERT EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE AND IF HE CAN'T WORK
IT OUT WITH DOJ THEY WILL SAY,
FINE, LET'S GO TO COURT, LET'S
EARN ANOTHER THREE, FOUR, FIVE,
SIX MONTHS.
>> YOU HEARD WHAT KATE LYNN SAID
AT THE END OF HER REPORTING IS
TRUMP'S LAWYERS ARE CAUTIONING
HIM IT MAY NOT BE THE BEST IDEA
TO TALK TO SOME OF THESE
WITNESSES, SPECIFICALLY HIS
ATTORNEYS ARE TELLING HIM OR
TOLD HIM THAT HE NEEDS TO STOP
TALKING TO MARK MEADOWS.
EXPLAIN WHY THEY'RE TELLING HIM
THAT.
>> I MEAN, AS YOU POINT OUT,
YEAH, IT'S NOT LIKELY TO CARRY
MUCH WEIGHT WITH HIM.
HE'S BEEN TOLD, I THINK, BY
EVERY LAWYER AND HE'S HAD MANY
NOT TO TALK TO POTENTIAL
WITNESSES, NOT TO TALK TO THE
PRESS.
HE GOES OUT, HE MAKES ADMISSIONS
AND DANGLES CARROTS AND
THREATENS WITNESSES.
SO MARK MEADOWS IN PARTICULAR
OBVIOUSLY WAS RIGHT UP CLOSE IN
THE PRESIDENT'S CIRCLE ON
JANUARY 6th AND ALSO OF COURSE
MANY OF THE EVENTS LEADING UP TO
IT.
SO HE'S GOING TO HAVE PLENTY OF
DIRECT EVIDENCE THAT WILL BE OF
GREAT INTEREST TO PROSECUTORS,
AND IT IS STANDARD FOR LAWYERS
TO GIVE THAT CAUTIONARY WARNING
TO THEIR CLIENTS, DON'T
TAMPER -- DON'T INTERFERE, STAY
AWAY, CAN ONLY HURT YOU, BUT,
YOU KNOW, WE SEE THIS ONCE AGAIN
AND IT DOES NOT SOUND LIKE HE IS
HEEDING THAT ADVICE THIS TIME
AROUND, EITHER.
JOINING US NOW IS ALBERTO
GONZALES, THE FORMER ATTORNEY
GENERAL AND FORMER COUNSEL TO
PRESIDENT GEORGE W. BUSH.
GENERAL GONZALEZ, GREAT TO SEE
YOU, SIR.
AS YOU HEARD, TRUMP'S LAWYERS
REPORTEDLY BELIEVE THAT THERE
WILL BE INDICTMENTS IN THIS CASE
BUT YOU HAVE VOICED SKEPTICISM
AT THE IDEA OF TRUMP BEING
INDICTED.
HOLD ON.
I'M JUST ASKING, HAVE ANY OF THE
LATEST DEVELOPMENTS CHANGED YOUR
MIND AROUND THAT?
>> WELL, LISTEN, I VOICED
SKEPTICISM BECAUSE WE SIMPLY
DON'T KNOW WHAT KIND OF EVIDENCE
THE DEPARTMENT IS GOING TO BE
SUCCESSFUL IN PRESENTING BEFORE
A JURY.
IT'S ONE THING TO MAKE THE
DECISIONS THAT WITH RESPECT TO
CRIMINALITY OF DONALD TRUMP
BASED UPON THE JANUARY 6th
COMMITTEE IT'S QUITE ANOTHER TO
ACTUALLY CONVICT HIM IN A COURT
OF LAW.
SO WE HAVE A RULE OF LAW IN THIS
COUNTRY AND I THINK THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE IS DOING
WHAT THEY SHOULD BE DOING,
GATHERING UP EVIDENCE AND THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL IS GOING TO
MAKE A CALCULATED DECISION AS TO
WHETHER OR NOT TO MOVE FORWARD
WITH AN INDICTMENT AND A FUTURE
PROSECUTION.
YOU KNOW, THIS HAS NEVER BEEN
DONE BEFORE WHERE A FORMER
PRESIDENT HAS BEEN INDICTED,
CHARGED AND PROSECUTED FOR
ACTIONS COMMITTED WHILE ACTUALLY
IN OFFICE.
SO IF YOU ARE GOING TO DO THIS,
YOU BETTER BE PRETTY SURE YOU'RE
GOING TO BE SUCCESSFUL BECAUSE
IF YOU INDICT HIM AND YOU ARE
NOT SUCCESSFUL IN PROSECUTING
HIM, THAT'S GOING TO EMBOLDEN
FUTURE -- SUCH LIKE FUTURE
CONDUCT, IT'S GOING TO INSPIRE
HIS SUPPORTERS AND SO, YOU KNOW,
YOU WANT TO BE VERY, VERY
CAREFUL ABOUT THIS.
LISTEN, IF THE EVIDENCE IS
THERE, I HAVE EVERY BELIEVE AND
CONFIDENCE THAT THEY WILL MOVE
FORWARD WITH THE PROSECUTION
BECAUSE THAT IS HIS OBLIGATION.
I KNOW SOME PEOPLE WERE
CONCERNED AS TO WHETHER OR NOT
THIS IS GOING TO DIVERT THE
ATTENTION OF LAWMAKERS FOR
SEVERAL MONTHS, WHETHER A
CRIMINAL TRIAL WILL DIVERT THE
ATTENTION OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
FOR A LONG PERIOD OF TIME.
I THINK GENERAL GARLAND DOESN'T
TAKE THAT INTO CONSIDERATION
MAKING THIS DECISION.
IF IN FACT THE NATION SHOULD BE
SPARED FROM A LONG CRIMINAL
TRIAL, THAT'S A DECISION FOR THE
PRESIDENT.
PRESIDENT BIDEN COULD ISSUE A
PARDON, FOR EXAMPLE, MUCH LIKE
PRESIDENT FORD DID IN THE NIXON
CASE.
>> OBVIOUSLY A TON OF
DIFFERENCES BUT I WANT TO ZERO
IN ON SOMETHING YOU SAID.
YOU KNOW, YOUR CONFIDENCE THAT
ATTORNEY GENERAL GARLAND IF THE
FACTS ARE THERE WOULD MOVE
FORWARD WITH A PROSECUTION.
IF THE FACTS WERE THERE AND YOU
WERE ATTORNEY GENERAL IS THAT
THE DECISION YOU WOULD MAKE?
>> YES, I THINK SO.
THAT WOULD BE MY JOB AS THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
AND THE OTHER THING THAT I WOULD
EMPHASIZE IS THAT THIS IS A
DECISION TO BE MADE WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
I WOULD NOT ANTICIPATE THAT
THERE WOULD BE COMMUNICATIONS
WITH THE WHITE HOUSE ABOUT THIS.
IN FACT, GENERAL GARLAND MAY
MAKE THE ANNOUNCEMENT OR MAKE
THE DECISION TO MOVE FORWARD
WITHOUT INFORMING THE WHITE
HOUSE BECAUSE WE HAVE TO HAVE
CONFIDENCE, PARTICULARLY WITH
RESPECT TO TRUMP'S SUPPORTERS.
THIS IS NOT A POLITICAL DECISION
INVOLVING THE WHITE HOUSE, THIS
WAS MADE BASED UPON THE
EVIDENCE, BASED UPON THE
PROFESSIONAL JUDGMENT OF
PROSECUTORS WITHIN THE DOENL.
THEY WILL MAKE THIS DECISION AND
THEY WILL ACT ON THAT DECISION
AND THEN THE WHITE HOUSE WILL
ACCEPT THAT DECISION.
>> IT'S VITALLY IMPORTANT THAT
JUSTICEN NONPARTISAN.
I THINK PEOPLE HAVE GOTTEN
JAUNDICED AROUND THAT.
LET'S GO TO EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE
BECAUSE THAT IS SOMETHING YOU
HAVE UNIQUE INSIGHT INTO AS A
FORMER U.S. COUNSEL.
NIXON VERSUS THE UNITED STATES
SEEMED TO SET ASIDE OR CLEARLY
DELINEATE THE LINES, EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE DOESN'T EXTEND TO
POTENTIAL CRIMINAL CONDUCT.
HOW DO YOU SEE THIS PLAYING OUT?
>> IT'S NOT SURPRISING THAT THE
NOTION OF EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE IS
AN ISSUE BEING DEBATED.
YOU ARE RIGHT WITH RESPECT TO
THE NIXON CASE IT'S QUITE CLEAR
THAT THE PRIVILEGE IS NOT
ABSOLUTE.
IT'S NOT GOING TO SHIELD
CRIMINAL CONDUCT.
CERTAINLY IF THERE IS NO OTHER
WAY TO GET THE INFORMATION
THAT'S IMPORTANT FOR A CRIMINAL
PROSECUTION.
AND THE OTHER THING TO REMEMBER
IS THAT IT'S A PRIVILEGE THAT
BELONGS IN ESSENCE TO THE OFFICE
OF THE PRESIDENT.
THE VIEWS OF THE SITTING
PRESIDENT CARRY MUCH MORE WEIGHT
IN THE COURT IN CONNECTION WITH
THE EXAMINATION OF EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE THAN A FORMER
PRESIDENT.
SO THE FACT THAT PRESIDENT BIDEN
HASN'T ASSERTED PRIVILEGE I
THINK IT'S GOING TO CARRY SOME
ADDITIONAL WEIGHT.
ALL THE CONSIDERATIONS AND
FACTORS THAT THE COURT WOULD
TYPICALLY CONSIDER IN WHETHER OR
NOT TO, YOU KNOW, REWARD OR
APPROVE OF EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE
SIMPLY DON'T EXIST HERE IN THE
FAVOR OF PRESIDENT TRUMP.